samedi à l'occasion des obsèques du
prince philip le royaume uni tout entier
était endeuillée par la disparition de
celui qui a été le mari de la reine
elizabeth ii depuis 1947 c'est avec un
profond chagrin que la reine annonce la
mort de son époux bien aimé c'est à 99
ans que le prince philippe a succombé
pour jean tout le pays la reine dans une
terrible tristesse devant leur
télévision des millions de britanniques
ont assisté à ses obsèques
une cérémonie retransmise à travers le
monde est marqué par un cliché qui a
beaucoup fait réagir celui de la reine
seul et vêtu de noir sur les bancs de
l'église d'une solitude une reine qui
devrait continuer à porter du noir
durant 30 jours comme le veut la
tradition lors d'un tel deuil
la cérémonie était aussi marquée par la
présence du prince harry est
actuellement en très mauvais termes avec
la famille royale et qui a reçu un
accueil glacial
des images qui ont fait le tour du monde
il est prévu que le corps du prince
philippe repose désormais dans les
jardins de phoques morts à l'ouest de
londres et de gate ans qui vient
d'arriver en direct je viens de mettre
des pmp il va la faire quand son
opération des yeux alors bertrand merci
d'être là mon bertron bonsoir qu'avez
vous pensé de cette cérémonie on va voir
que deux ou trois passages
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé de la
cérémonie un très belle cérémonie
émouvante en effet allé très très
marquée par le corps d'un virus c'est
vrai pour moi l'impression qu'il n'y
avait pas trente invités peut-être mais
31 ans que lorsque coronas et être
invité lui aussi bel arrêt
seuls étaient figés alors à 14h45
exactement qui a démarré à démarrer de
land rover emportant le prince philibert
la chapelle c'est lui même qui l'avait
dessiné un oui
derrière ces quatre enfants suivaient à
pied et la reine était dans sa benne clé
regardez en tête des villes sans fin
le lagarde suivi par tous les chefs
militaires des forces armées
britanniques et derrière donc le cortège
royal vous observé qu' aucun des invités
n'étant costume militaire
c'est normal c'était un souhait de la
reine pour ne pas faire polémique parce
que vous savez que depuis le mexique le
prince harry a été démis de ses de ses
titres militaire et elle ne souhaitait
pas qu'il y ait des différences entre
les deux frères est là justement on voit
william et harry séparés par l'or
olympique heures phillips a ouais ouais
ouais on les voies séparées et ils se
sont parlés harry et william
oui et tout cela grâce à kate middleton
est exact alors on va revoir la scène
parce que c'est ça qui a marqué aussi
cette cérémonie les mots échangés entre
harry et william
regardez sont rentrés de la chapelle au
château royal à pied ensemble et ça lui
parler alors que leur relation n'était
pas au fond ce moment c'était pas la
folie et harry et william j'ai
l'impression que là peut-être que là
c'était le moment pour se rabibocher
pivot chinois qui sont dit bertrand ou
pas non non la presse l'ancien couvent
alors c'est grâce à kate
c'est grâce à kate on va très mal ces
quêtes qui le ramène en quelque sorte
est bien select elle est très fine qui
est allé très très fissiles à fins
régime du pénis non mais j'adore kate
middleton oui il ya surtout un message
qui a été envoyé par la reine astrid à
vic est je crois que steevy ici doit
savoir à quel point la reine une ouvre
ses coffres à bijoux avec parcimonie
elle traite très peu et là elle a prêté
à kate middleton la cérémonie au rang de
perles et quatre rangs de perles et plus
exactement alors c'est pas anecdotique
loin de là aurait été un bijoux
ostentatoires
bref c'est un bijou que l'on devait voir
qu'à se rendre vers la loi donnait win a
déjà prêté un boulet c'est en quelque
sorte une façon de montrer au monde
parce qu'elle savait très bien que tu y
es tu allais être scrutés par les
caméras du monde entier juré le fait en
quelque sorte de kate middleton sont
héritières ça c'est la faute
le collier sans rigoler les têtes
middleton elle doit être comme une
falaise 10 avec moi là mais une matrone
des réalités très royal quand elle a
pris le costume du royal s'est la future
terre c'est la future n amène à combler
mais il devient roi camilla ne sera que
princesse consort hétéro le même statut
que le principal objectif aura le titre
de reine d'angleterre
c'est dingue à 6,5 s'il vous plaît on aa
renégats rebelles qui peut parler de
megan n'était pas là parce que certains
parlent de sa grossesse on a du mal à y
croire on a ça commence à faire pas
légal on s'arrange à elle même elle ne
redoutait pas tellement dit on les
réactions de la famille royale elle
redoutait plus les réactions de la
presse tabloïd
c'est ça vaut bien se dire en angleterre
que la presse est le premier des
pouvoirs et des surtout la presse dont
elle a besoin d' alors pour faire
carrière elle a besoin de la presse en
amérique ils ont besoin d'arrêts d'alep
envie de l'avoir non ben disons que la
reine elle a d'autres chats à fouetter à
l'heure actuelle c'est vrai et mégane
elles sont tombées ou pas apparemment
non mais enfin la duchesse de sussex et
la duchesse de cambridge ce n'est pas le
grand am
elles peuvent pas se blairer bas nylon
qui inquiète car dame qui a un coeur de
la tradition qui incarna la monarchie en
face des lits à une américaine qui est
un peu enfant gâté ah ouais c'est vrai
vous êtes plus kate ou mégane vous je
suis à fond quitte middleware
c'est parmi ces voix de beth gibbons
glisser une biche ah oui elle a fait
envoyer alors elle a regardé en
livestream mégane et a fait envoyer une
couronne de fleurs avec des chardons
pour la marine elle était passionnée de
calligraphier elle a fait un mot voilà
mais c'est la seule chose qu'elle a
faite de loin certainement et son
histoire pour moi c'est pipeau pipeau de
la classe avancée
oui tout ça est très vrai mais moi ça me
gêne c'est les obsèques et y avait pas
une once de sincérité
la mise en scène les deux frères qui se
reparlent comme par hasard là vous nous
dites les bijoux un café à travers les
obsèques
on avait l'impression que c'était là
mais la roja mais la roya crète et la
salle image très forte de la cérémonie
willy sagnol arrête oui moi elle est
assis seul sur son banc à cause des
restrictions sanitaires elles n'étaient
pas filmés pendant la cérémonie
mais plusieurs photos sont sortis
regardez voilà et c'est vrai que je
craigne que l'on s'aperçoit vraiment que
cette femme qui règne sur 140 millions
de sujets à travers le globe
la première fois on a l'impression que
qu'elle ne porte plus cette cuirasse
c'est ça qui fait d'elle avec sa voix
des larrieu miniers dit la première fois
qu'on voit là policiers c'est la non non
vraiment il suit noël à ma passion que
c'était avec les enfants quand ya eu des
mouvements le britannia la clau
qu'est-ce qu'elle ne l'avait pas plus
riches et qui avait vu pleurer là le
rythme et blu ray non je n'ai pas vu
plus vraiment que c'est une cérémonie
absolument sublime très émouvant très
solennelle ça a été suivi par 13
millions de téléspectateurs avec la bbc
3 millions sur tf1 deux millions cinq
sur france 2 c'est quand même incroyable
on n'arrête pas de nous parler de
modernité progressivement fait ça
passionne les gens le côté archaïque
comme ça le côté vieillot de la royauté
moi je trouve que c'est passionnant
alors l'arête de la politique lancée à
wayne non mais moi je peux pas entendre
que c'était une mise en scène parce que
vraiment c'est très touchant et en plus
je trouve que c'est tellement dur
justement être filmée dans ces moments
là parce que c'est les moments de
déchirements et la terre entière vous
regarde donc je pense que dire que
c'était une mise en scène si assez bas
de la mi temps c'est du protocole voilà
oui c'est du protocole williams linge
est régie par le protocole si on peut
regarder un petit peu la mise en beauté
de la reine tu vois bien que ça peut pas
être un truc mise en scène parce qu'elle
tient tellement à son image que tu
l'aurais vu en pente un peu plus
maquillée
là on voit bien qu'avec elle a vraiment
grise mine al ça va pas du tout elle
n'est pas maquillée
on voit très bien que ça lui que c'est
vrai que je sais pas c'est pas tricher
quoi te jure je l'aï vu moi j'ai des
jeux les bus darren le gallo en antoine
griezmann d'ailleurs je t'embrasse monde
antoine des mots